I'm being space jammed!
Tim! Tim! Wake up!
Am I dead? Is this heaven?
No! You just watched so much anime
that you got sent into our world.
You've basically achieved a
higher level of consciousness.
From... Watching anime?
Yup! Check this out!
Anime Awards Genjutsu!
Dang, Hime! When did ya learn how to do that?
I've had a lot of free time lately.
You need a better outfit.
Whoa! I'm lookin' good as hell. Thanks, Hime.
Now that you're here in the anime
world, anything is possible.
Anything, huh?
So I could have friends, and we
could make an anime together?
Yeah! If you have at least two friends, sure!
Turn into a lizard man who loves dumplings?
Uh-huh.
Eat some demon fingies?
Uh-huh!
Or I could start the Anime Awards?
Yeah!
Alrighty!
Hey, everyone!
We are gathered here for this special
night in the anime community
where fans and industry come together
to honor the best of the best in anime.
We have a lot ahead, including special
announcements and anime previews,
messages from creators in Japan,
and of course, all of our
award winners revealed.
We also have some friends around
the world co-streaming the awards.
You're welcome to watch with
them on their channels.
Say "Hello" everyone!
Hello Everyone!
Hola Crunchyroll!
Welcome to the Anime Awards!
Fun fact: Tonight's nominees were
determined by two rounds of voting.
The first from a panel
of fifty esteemed judges,
then we turned to you: the public,
who came at us loud and clear with
millions and millions of votes.
Thank you, everyone, and a big
thank you to tonight's sponsor
Princess Connect! Re:Dive! The most
anticipated mobile RPG from Japan!
Now available worldwide.
We couldn't have done it
without you, Priconne!
But! Before we start, Tim, I
am going to do one more thing.
Okay! Now without further ado...
In a sea of half-demons and cat girls,
a good character design
can make or break a show.
From slick con men to
bathroom-haunting ghosts,
here are the nominees for
Best Character Design:
RUMIKO TAKAHASHI & YOSHIHITO HISHINUMA
YASHAHIME: PRINCESS HALF-DEMON
GENICE CHAN & YUUSUKE YOSHIGAKI
BNA: BRAND NEW ANIMAL
YOSHIYUKI SADAMOTO & HIROTAKA KATOU
GREAT PRETENDER
NAOYUKI ASANO
ORIGINAL DESIGNS BY SUMITO OOWARA
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
MAYUKA ITO
ORIGINAL DESIGNS - AIDAIRO
TOILET-BOUND HANAKO-KUN
MASASHI KUDOH & MIHO TANINO
ORIGINAL STORY BY - SIU
TOWER OF GOD
And the winner for Best
Character Design is...
MAYUKA ITO
ORIGINAL DESIGNS - AIDAIRO
TOILET-BOUND HANAKO-KUN
At the heart of every
anime is... the animation.
It's the language animators
use to tell a story,
and show us things you never
see outside of the series.
Let's meet our nominees for Best Animation.
THE GOD OF HIGH SCHOOL
MAPPA
BEASTARS
ORANGE
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
Science SARU
JUJUTSU KAISEN
MAPPA
PRINCESS CONNECT! RE: DIVE
CYGAMESPICTURES
GREAT PRETENDER
WIT STUDIO
And the winner for Best Animation is...
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
Science SARU
We anime fans love fight scenes.
Whether it's complex and through
the fight choreography,
or the emotional peak of
two characters' conflict.
Let's take a look at the
Best Battles of 2020:
DEKU VS. OVERHAUL
MY HERO ACADEMIA SEASON 4
BRAWLER VS. MASTER
AKUDAMA DRIVE
SATORU GOJO VS. RYOMEN SUKUNA
JUJUTSU KAISEN
JIN MORI VS HAN DAEWI
THE GOD OF HIGH SCHOOL
BERCOULI VS. DARK GOD VECTA
SWORD ART ONLINE ALICIZATION:
WAR OF THE UNDERWORLD PART 2
JIN MORI VS. JEGAL TAEK
THE GOD OF HIGH SCHOOL
And the winner for Best Fight Scene is...
DEKU VS. OVERHAUL
MY HERO ACADEMIA SEASON 4
All is fair in love and war.
Since we've covered the battles,
it's time to move on to romance.
Rabbits and wolves.
College students and girlfriends for hire.
Let's take a look at Best Couple:
NASA YUZAKI & TSUKASA YUZAKI
TONIKAWA: OVER THE MOON FOR YOU
CHIZURU MIZUHARA & KAZUYA KINOSHITA
RENT-A-GIRLFRIEND
LEGOSHI & HARU
BEASTARS
KAGUYA SHINOMIYA & MIYUKI SHIROGANE
KAGUYA-SAMA: LOVE IS WAR
CATARINA CLAES & MARIA CAMPBELL
MY NEXT LIFE AS A VILLAINESS:
ALL ROUTES LEAD TO DOOM!
KOTO IWANAGA & KURO SAKURAGAWA
IN/SPECTRE
And the winner for Best Couple is...
NASA YUZAKI & TSUKASA YUZAKI
From TONIKAWA: OVER THE MOON FOR YOU
Writing and animation are only a part
of a fully realized anime character
You also need a voice actor to
truly breathe life into them.
Let's take a look at this year's nominees
for best Voice Actor Performance (Japanese).
YUICHI NAKAMURA
SATORU GOJO
JUJUTSU KAISEN
If you think I'm the only
one who'll be fighting back,
you're going to get hurt, old man.
YUSUKE KOBAYASHI
NATSUKI SUBARU
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD - (SEASON 2)
you're good to me and you love me,
but you're also stricter
with me than anyone else.
Rem is the one girl who
doesn't go easy on me!
MUTSUMI TAMURA
SAYAKA KANAMORI
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF OF EIZOUKEN!
A club making claims on other activities
with no actual intent of engaging in them
is a nuisance to other groups.
MEGUMI OGATA
HANAKO KUN
TOILET-BOUND HANAKO-KUN
In exchange, I'll take...
...your labor.
RIHO SUGIYAMA
MINARE KODA
WAVE, LISTEN TO ME!
"There's always a looming sense of
doom when it comes to my future.
Miss Minare, are you familiar
with that feeling?"
What is this fluff?
YUSUKE ONUKI
DAISUKE KAMBE
The Millionaire Detective - Balance: UNLIMITED
Under current circumstances, the smoke will
be effective for 8 minutes and 30 seconds.
We'll finish everything
within that timeframe.
And the winner for Best Voice
Actor Performance (Japanese) is...
YUSUKE KOBAYASHI
NATSUKI SUBARU
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD - (SEASON 2)
You like me and I like you,
you're good to me and you love me,
but you're also stricter
with me than anyone else.
Rem is the one girl who
doesn't go easy on me!
Hello, everyone!
I'm Yusuke Kobayashi, the voice of Subaru Natsuki
in Re:ZERO - Starting Life In Another World - Season 2.
I'm thrilled to accept the award for Best
Japanese Voice Actor in Crunchyroll's Anime Awards.
I really can't believe I won.
All I've done is just charge
into the role as Subaru Natsuki.
But I'm more glad for the
love Subaru has received
than I am for myself.
Thank you for so warmly accepting him.
And if my voice has left something
in your hearts through Subaru,
nothing could make me happier as an actor.
I'll keep doing my best to
move all of your hearts.
To all the fans around the
world, who support this anime,
to everyone who participated
in this awards show,
to the original author,
and to all the anime cast and staff,
I want to send you all my sincerest thanks.
Please continue to support
the series as well as myself.
This was Yusuke Kobayashi.
English voice actors take on the hard
task of bringing beloved characters
to a brand-new audience,
while preserving the things
that make them special.
Here are the nominees for Best
Voice Actor Performance (English):
ZENO ROBINSON
HAWKS
MY HERO ACADEMIA SEASON 4
I don't have enough feathers...
So I will focus on those in the most danger!
JONAH SCOTT
LEGOSHI
BEASTARS
Do I look like the devil to you?
Don't worry, Haru.
ANAIRIS QUIÑONES
ECHIDNA
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD - (SEASON 2)
Let me affirm the desires, the curiosities
and the greed that you seek
to satisfy with answers.
AARON PHILLIPS
LAURENT THIERRY
GREAT PRETENDER
This uses their advanced pharmaceuticals
and the latest synthetic narcotic.
It's magic.
"Sakura magic."
CRISPIN FREEMAN
ZIUSUDRA
FATE/GRAND ORDER ABSOLUTE DEMONIC FRONT: BABYLONIA
No need for dismay, I still owe you a favor.
A callow neophyte you may be, but your
steadfastness compensates for it.
JOHNNY YONG BOSCH
BAM
TOWER OF GOD
I didn't know that word yet at the
time, but it's how I felt in my heart.
No one could ever replace you.
And the winner for Best Voice
Actor Performance in English is...
ZENO ROBINSON
HAWKS
MY HERO ACADEMIA SEASON 4
I won't be able to get
everyone out of the building.
I don't have enough feathers...
So I will focus on those in the most danger!
Everyone! Ah wow! Thank you so much.
I am honored
and blessed to accept the Crunchyroll
award for best performance in English
as Hawks in My Hero Academia.
I love the show. I love working
on it. I love everyone involved.
In my heart of hearts, I am accepting
this alongside Anairis and Jonah,
who I am big fans of. They
inspire me to be better,
and I love you both.
And I'd like to dedicate this moment,
this award, this achievement
to all my actors of color out there,
and anime fans of color out there,
my black actors
and the black anime fans who have
carried this medium on their back
and our culture for as long
as I have been a fan of it.
We may not have always felt represented,
or seen, or reflected
in this medium
because you all love anime. So I see you.
I love you.
Thank you. God bless.
Heyo!
Oh, this is a pretty good Anime
Awards, if I do say so myself.
We're doing a great job.
Can you believe Toilet-Bound Hanako-Kun \Nwon for best character design?
I mean, what's not to love
about a haunted toilet?
I could think of a few things,
but how about Zeno Robinson
bringing home the win as Hawks?
Man, the only thing that could
make this better would be a...
World Premiere.
So... Are you happy?
You can run away at any time.
It's not like I've trapped you
in here or tied you down.
You came here on your own.
So where to?
Hello, everyone watching the Anime Awards!
I'm Natsuki Hanae.
Thank you for always loving
Japanese anime so much.
I will be voicing the protagonist
Odokawa in the anime Odd Taxi.
Odokawa doesn't really like
to get involved with others.
He's pretty stubborn, reserved,
and a rather unique taxi driver.
Odd Taxi is a show about Odokawa
having seemingly meaningless conversations
with his unique customers
eventually leading to a missing girl.
This is an original animation
like you've never seen before.
Please check out this series!
Watch on Crunchyroll!
On that day, I lost everything.
I can't die yet.
Not until I have my revenge.
The 64th year of the Meiji Era.
Tokugawa Yoshinobu still reigns.
Things look nice and peaceful on the surface
thanks to Yoshinobu-sama, don't they?
Tokugawa Yoshinobu still reigns.
Things look nice and peaceful on the surface
thanks to Yoshinobu-sama, don't they?
But they don't know a thing.
Hey, Yuki onee-chan!
Sentiment can be cruel.
I know, because my emotions get
the best of me sometimes, as well.
What a boring bunch.
If you're going to fall,
why not dance with as many butterflies
as you can, on the way down?
Get rid of any emotions you don't need.
I'm going to use you
to purify Nue.
And you're going to use
me to get your revenge.
Get your revenge on me in Hell.
I'll join you there soon enough.
PRINCESS CONNECT! Re:Dive
PLAY NOW
Buried deep in every anime fan's heart
is the answer to one urgent question:
Who is best girl?
We've got some formidable
contenders this year.
So let's meet the nominees for Best Girl:
NOI
DOROHEDORO
SAYAKA KANAMORI
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
CHIZURU MIZUHARA
RENT-A-GIRLFRIEND
CATARINA CLAES
MY NEXT LIFE AS A VILLAINESS:
ALL ROUTES LEAD TO DOOM!
KAGUYA SHINOMIYA
Kaguya-sama: Love is War?
ABIGAIL JONES
GREAT PRETENDER
And the winner for Best Girl is...
KAGUYA SHINOMIYA
Kaguya-sama: Love is War?
What are the elements of a Best Boy?
Is it an unbreakable spirit?
Unbeatable good looks?
The ability to control the terrifying,
unknowable horror of infinity?
Or being a cute wolf man?
Let's take a look at the contenders:
ANOS VOLDIGOAD
THE MISFIT OF DEMON KING ACADEMY
CAIMAN
DOROHEDORO
SATORU GOJO
JUJUTSU KAISEN
SHOYO HINATA
HAIKYU!! TO THE TOP
KHUN AGUERO AGNES
TOWER OF GOD
LEGOSHI
BEASTARS
Ans the winner for Best Boy is...
SHOYO HINATA
HAIKYU!! TO THE TOP
Directing is hard work!
Your part artist. Part HR department.
Part office administrator and all passion.
Directors brought us amazing series in 2020.
So let's take a look at
the cream of the crop:
HIRO KABURAGI
GREAT PRETENDER
MASAAKI YUASA
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF OF EIZOUKEN!
SUNGHOO PARK
JUJUTSU KAISEN
TAKASHI SANO
TOWER OF GOD
YUZURU TACHIKAWA
DECA-DENCE
MAMORU HATAKEYAMA
Kaguya-sama: Love is War?
And the winner for Best Director is...
MASAAKI YUASA
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF OF EIZOUKEN!
Thank you so much Crunchyroll
and animation fans.
I'm truly honored to have won Best Animation for Eizouken and
Best Director at the Crunchyroll Anime Awards. Thank you.
I didn't realise so many people would be
interested in animation so I'm very happy.
While I was working on this series,
I would occasionally
send messages to the author, Owara-san, to ask questions.
We also made the ending sequence together.
Those are very fond memories.
I'm very thankful to everyone
who supported our endeavors.
Thank you very much.
When an anime score is at its best,
the music sets the tone for an entire series.
Whether that's beginning of a
heist, the height of the battle...
Within the character's imagination.
Please welcome the nominees for Best Score:
YUTAKA YAMADA
GREAT PRETENDER
ALISA OKEHAZAMA
THE GOD OF HIGH SCHOOL
OORUTAICHI
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF OF EIZOUKEN!
KENSUKE USHIO
JAPAN SINKS: 2020
KEVIN PENKIN
TOWER OF GOD
SATORU KOUSAKI
BEASTARS
And the winner for Best Score is...
KEVIN PENKIN
TOWER OF GOD
Hey everyone. My name is Kevin Penkin.
I'm the composer for Tower of God.
I just want to say a huge, huge thank
you for this award. It's a great honor.
I would also like to thank
all the fans of Tower of God.
You guys are awesome and I love your passion.
So thank you so much to you.
I would also like to thank all of the
co-composers I've been working with on this soundtrack.
People like feeding | ear,
Mason Lieberman, Jeremy Lim,
James Landino, Ben Matthews and Raj Ramayya.
You guys are fantastic people. Thank
you so much for being a part of this.
And yet I hope everyone is safe,
healthy and I hope to see you soon.
Have a great day.
A good anime opening can perfectly
capture a show's sensibility
and distill it into a few minutes of bliss.
Please welcome the nominees
for Best Opening Sequence:
HAIKYU!! TO THE TOP
♪PHOENIX - BURNOUT SYNDROMES
ANIMATION DIRECTOR - MASAKO SATO
STORYBOARD ARTIST - MASAKO SATO
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
♪Easy Breezy - chelmico
STORYBOARDS - MASAAKI YUASA
GREAT PRETENDER
♪G.P. - YUTAKA YAMADA
DIRECTION - KOTOMI DEAI
SOLO KEY ANIMATION - SACHIKO MATSUMOTO
BEASTARS
♪WILD SIDE - ALI
STORYBOARD, DIRECTION AND EDITING - MICHIYA KATOU
Kaguya-sama: Love is War?
♪DADDY! DADDY! DO! FEAT. AIRI SUZUKI - MASAYUKI SUZUKI
STORYBOARD & DIRECTION - RYU ANDO
ANIMATION DIRECTION - YUKO HARIBA
Kaguya-sama: Love is War? (Season 2)
JUJUTSU KAISEN
♪KAIKAI KITAN - EVE
CHIEF ANIMATION DIRECTION - TADASHI HIRAMATSU
STORYBOARD & DIRECTION - SHINGO YAMASHITA
And the winner for Best
Opening Sequence is...
BEASTARS
♪WILD SIDE - ALI
STORYBOARD, DIRECTION AND EDITING - MICHIYA KATOU
Now, anime fans know some of the best tunes
come after the episode is over.
These next songs have us watching
until the very last credit.
Please welcome the nominees
for Best Ending Sequence:
BNA: BRAND NEW ANIMAL
♪NIGHT RUNNING - SHIN SAKURA FT AAAMYYY
ART & ANIMATION DIRECTION - GENICE CHAN
BNA: BRAND NEW ANIMAL
DOROHEDORO
♪D.D.D.D. - (K)NoW_NAME
GAME GRAPHICS - sankaku△
STORYBOARD & DIRECTION - YUICHIRO HAYASHI
IN/SPECTRE
♪LAST DANCE - MAMORU MIYANO
ANIMATION DIRECTOR - KEIJI GOTO
STORYBOARD ARTIST - KEIJI GOTO
GREAT PRETENDER
♪THE GREAT PRETENDER - FREDDIE MERCURY
STORYBOARD & DIRECTION - HIRO KABURAGI
SOLO KEY ANIMATION - ATSUKO NOZAKI
JUJUTSU KAISEN
♪LOST IN PARADISE - ALI FEAT. AKLO
STORYBOARD & DIRECTION - MASATSUGU NAGASOE
SOLO KEY ANIMATION - YUUKI IGARASHI
JUJUTSU KAISEN
The Millionaire Detective - Balance: UNLIMITED
♪WELCOME MY FRIEND - OKAMOTO'S
STORYBOARD, DIRECTION, SOLO KEY ANIMATION,
BACKGROUNDS, AND COMPOSITING - YASUAKI KUROZU
The Millionaire Detective
- Balance: UNLIMITED
And the winner for Best Ending is...
JUJUTSU KAISEN
LOST IN PARADISE - ALI FEAT. AKLO
I loved hearing from some
of our favorite creators.
I know! All this excitement though
is uh, kinda making me hungry.
Maybe I'll get a banana split...
You think they feel weird
about selling bananas?
Ya know... As food...
I think it's time
for some more announcements
and special guests!
Roll the tape...
No... after we finally all managed
to get on stage together...
It can't end like this...
It ain't over yet!
Now, get your butts on the stage and
give the crowd a taste of your souls!
It was a crazy idea from the start...
This zombies-as-idols business.
Hell, Saga itself is barely hanging in there!
If we don't get better, we'll never
be more than third-rate idols.
That will mean never getting our revenge.
I suppose we could build
a whole new Saga, then.
It'll be okay! And Franchouchou's
gonna get revenge!
I want to get on stage again!
I'm not gonna let anything stop me!
Smash it!
Show business has always been
a competition where you have
to constantly be on your toes.
I'll show you what kind of show
the reigning champions can put on.
We'll have to make the show
a success by ourselves.
I chose you all to save Saga,
and brought you back to life,
because nothing is impossible for you!
REVENGE!
Airing April 2021
Hello everyone! I'm the director of
ZOMBIE LAND SAGA REVENGE, Munehisa Sakai.
ZOMBIE LAND SAGA REVENGE is going to
be full of more unpredictable twist
and wonderful songs, and I really
hope you will all enjoy it.
We've been pouring even more passion
into our work than Season 1,
maybe a bit too much
at times, to the point
but our entire staff is working together
tomake sure it turns out great,
so please look forward to it!
Make sure to check out ZOMBIE LAND
SAGA REVENGE on Crunchyroll
Thank you very much!
Hello Crunchyroll Anime Awards viewers!
I'm Kobayashi Yuusuke,
the voice of Natsuki Subaru
in Re:ZERO -Starting Life in Another World-.
And I'm Takahashi Rie,
the voice of Emilia. Hello!
So Re:ZERO -Starting Life in Another World-
is streaming around the world,
making it even more popular.
Yay!
Thank you so much!
And we're told that the second cour
of the second season is now streaming.
Are you all making sure to watch it?
Thank you!
Yes, the second cour of the second season
should be around the halfway point by now.
Yes.
I think this is a good time to share
the stand-out features
of our characters, Emilia and Subaru,
at this point in the story.
Well, Subaru...
He's been through a lot
of very painful experiences,
and now he's getting more scenes
about the amazing things he does
to brush all that off.
That's true.
It was starting to feel like a lot of...
circumstances... were closing in on him,
but now, as you can even see
in the opening sequence,
he starts to actually fight.
Yeah. Actually...
His interactions with Garfiel
have really stuck in my mind.
Oh!
They're both characters that yell a lot,
so if one lashes out with one exclamation
point, the other will hit back with two.
Then three, and in the end...
It's not actually in the script,
but I can imagine ten exclamation
points on a single line!
So I was told, "You went
a bit too far there."
You got a little too passionate.
Yeah, yeah.
That's just how heated they get
with each other.
That episode left a deep impression on me.
Wow, that's a good one.
How about Emilia-tan?
For Emilia, the big thing is that she started undergoing her trial in Ep42.
Well, she started it, but it's more like
her real trial has yet to begin,
and I think everyone will be able to
learn a lot more about Emilia from it.
I got to know Emilia a lot better myself
by voicing her in this episode,
and it made me want to
hold on to that feeling
while I voice her from now on
so I can enjoy this arc along
with all the viewers.
Speaking of ep40... Emilia-tan...
Ah, the special ending theme!
Yes, there's a song I sang as Emilia
that'll be used as an ending theme.
I hope that, after watching
that scene in the episode,
everyone will pay close attention
to the voice and lyrics in that song.
This turned out to be mostly about us,
but all the other characters,
like Garfiel, Ram, and all the others...
Yes, there are lots of them.
Yes and they each get their
own moment in the spotlight.
You won't want to tear your
eyes away for a moment
as the second season dives
into its second half.
Please make sure you don't miss it!
So this has been Kobayashi Yuusuke,
the voice of Natsuki Subaru
in Re:ZERO -Starting Life in Another World-...
And Takahashi Rie, the voice of Emilia.
One, two...
Watch on Crunchyroll!
Whether the series started life
in another world, grueling tower,
or a post-apocalyptic cityscape
overflowing with mushrooms,
the nominees for Best Fantasy
took place in amazing locales.
Please welcome the nominees for Best Fantasy:
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD -
(SEASON 2)
WHITE FOX
DOROHEDORO
MAPPA
DECA-DENCE
NUT
TOWER OF GOD
TELECOM ANIMATION FILM
ASCENDANCE OF A BOOKWORM
PART 2
AJIA-DO ANIMATION WORKS
DRAGON QUEST THE ADVENTURE OF DAI
TOEI ANIMATION
And the winner for Best Fantasy is...
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD -
(SEASON 2)
WHITE FOX
Once upon a time, a clown invented comedy
and plenty of anime last year carried
that clown's legacy forward.
Please welcome the nominees for Best Comedy:
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
Science SARU
MY NEXT LIFE AS A VILLAINESS:
ALL ROUTES LEAD TO DOOM!
SILVER LINK.
KAKUSHIGOTO
AJIA-DO ANIMATION WORKS
SLEEPY PRINCESS IN THE DEMON CASTLE
DOGA KOBO
THE MISFIT OF DEMON KING ACADEMY
SILVER LINK.
Kaguya-sama: Love is War? (SEASON 2)
A-1 PICTURES
And the winner for Best Comedy is...
Kaguya-sama: Love is War? (SEASON 2)
A-1 PICTURES
Some of the most gripping moments in
anime this past year came from dramas.
Each of the following shows had
us at the edge of our seats.
Let's see what show made the biggest impact.
Please welcome the nominees for Best Drama:
BEASTARS
ORANGE
FRUITS BASKET (SEASON 2)
TMS ENTERTAINMENT
GREAT PRETENDER
WIT STUDIO
JAPAN SINKS: 2020
Science SARU
SING "YESTERDAY" FOR ME
DOGA KOBO
SOMALI AND THE FOREST SPIRIT
SATELIGHT, HORNETS
And the winner for Best Drama is...
FRUITS BASKET (SEASON 2)
TMS ENTERTAINMENT
We all know there can be no anime
with no main characters, duh.
This year's Best Protagonist features stars
from the court, to the drawing board,
everything in between.
Please welcome the nominees
for Best Protagonist:
NATSUME
DECA-DENCE
SHOYO HINATA
HAIKYU!! TO THE TOP
YUJI ITADORI
JUJUTSU KAISEN
MIDORI ASAKUSA
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
CATARINA CLAES
MY NEXT LIFE AS A VILLAINESS:
ALL ROUTES LEAD TO DOOM!
ANOS VOLDIGOAD
THE MISFIT OF DEMON KING ACADEMY
And the winner for Best Protagonist is...
CATARINA CLAES
MY NEXT LIFE AS A VILLAINESS:
ALL ROUTES LEAD TO DOOM!
Villains...
Whether you love to hate
them or hate to love them
Let's take a look at the wicked
line up for our next category.
Please welcome the nominees
for Best Antagonist:
EN
DOROHEDORO
OVERHAUL
MY HERO ACADEMIA SEASON 4
RYOMEN SUKUNA
JUJUTSU KAISEN
AKITO SOMA
FRUITS BASKET (SEASON 2)
ECHIDNA
RE:ZERO - STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD -
(SEASON 2)
RACHEL
TOWER OF GOD
And the winner for Best Antagonist is...
RYOMEN SUKUNA
JUJUTSU KAISEN
Ryomen Sukuna for Best Antagonist? Wow!
It is truly a treat to celebrate all
of these great characters and creators.
So, let's take a moment to shine a
little light on this evening's sponsor
as a thank you.
Princess Connect! Re:Dive has
some pretty spicy villains, too.
Like a certain mysterious fox we'll see soon.
They're like me, but way scarier.
This game is jam-packed
with adorable heroines.
It's got something for everyone.
So, let's check it out.
Princess Connect! Re:Dive
We also have an exclusive preview
and cast commentary for Tokyo Revengers.
I love this series!
It's got it all. Mysteries, time travel,
delinquents, peak aesthetics
and it's all jam-packed in a dude's quest
to save the only girlfriend he's ever had.
Let's roll the tape.
Hello! I'm Yuuki Shin and
I play Takemichi Hanagaki.
Thank you for watching the
Crunchyroll Anime Awards.
In Tokyo Revengers, Takemichi Hangaki, a
failure of a part-timer at the end of his ropes,
ends up traveling back in time to when he was
at his peak in middle school.
In order to save his one and only girlfriend,
Hinata Tachibana, and protect her
as well as try to change his own life,
he tries to get revenge on his life.
This is one of the best
passionate and bittersweet
time-travel suspense stories you'll see.
Takemichi Hanagaki, who I play,
will protect Hina at all costs.
In order to save her and his
friends, he's going to change
the version of himself that
he'd been running away from
and face any hardships.
He is a very cool character.
I am putting everything
I have into this role.
It's going to be an amazing series,
so please watch it on Crunchyroll.
Hello, everyone. I'm eill.
Thank you for watching the
Crunchyroll Anime Awards.
I will be singing the ending
theme for Tokyo Revengers.
The song "Koko de Iki wo Shite"
is a song that depicts
Hinata Tachibana's feelings.
"True love can survive any place and
time and you just need to breathe,"
were my thoughts writing this song.
I hope you can all find a
place like that as well.
Please watch Tokyo Revengers on Crunchyroll.
Thank you!
It's been an amazing evening so far and we
couldn't have done it without all of you!
Let's throw it over to our fans to hear
their predictions for anime of the year.
For anime of the Year I chose
Keep Your Hands Off Eizouken!
will win Anime of the Year
both for it's inventiveness and for its
importance in the world of anime.
I think Dorohedoro deserves
to win Anime of the Year.
I think it has a super amazing setting,
I love its entire cast of characters...
Dorohedoro for the win.
I think that Appare-Ranman! \Nshould be Anime of the Year
because it has a really diverse cast
with a lot of great synergy.
The Anime of the Year will be JUJUTSU KAISEN
because I absolutely love the characters
and the incredible fights in the series.
It's simply JUJUTSU KAISEN!
JUJUTSU KAISEN.
BEASTARS.
I think BEASTARS will win Anime of the Year.
I think BEASTARS really pushed
the limits on modern anime.
The Anime of the Year at the Anime Awards?
Honestly I hope it will be Great Pretender!
Great Pretender.
I gotta go with Great Pretender.
Second season was fire.
There have been a lot of
fantastic winners tonight.
Each show the tremendous effort and talent
that went into producing the
art we all love and cherish.
Anime brought us new worlds,
new powers and new friends.
Anime was there to give us the strength
we needed to face every new day
no matter how hard it was.
But now,
it is time to look at the best of the best,
and for all to come together
and decide who will win this
year's most prestigious award.
But before we meet these
Anime of the Year nominees,
a message from the last year's winner.
Hello everyone!
I am Yuma Takahashi, one of the producers
of Demon Slayer: Kimetsu no Yaiba.
We were truly honored to receive
the Anime of the Year award last year.
I would like to extend our heartfelt
thanks to the Crunchyroll Anime Awards
for this prestigious award
and all the fans for their support.
It has been such a humbling experience
to see the fans' response to the show
and we are extremely grateful
for the love you have shown
for the characters and the story.
We hope you are looking forward to
joining Tanjiro on his next mission
when Demon Slayer - Kimetsu no
Yaiba - The Movie: Mugen Train
is available in theaters in North America.
On behalf of the staff of Demon
Slayer: Kimetsu no Yaiba,
we would like to wish the best
of luck to all the nominees
of Crunchyroll Anime Awards
2021, Anime of the Year!
Thank you very much!
It is my great pleasure
to announce the nominees
for Anime of the Year.
The nominees are:
JUJUTSU KAISEN
MAPPA
DOROHEDORO
GREAT PRETENDER
WIT STUDIO
BEASTARS
ORANGE
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF EIZOUKEN!
Science SARU
APPARE-RANMAN!
P.A.WORKS
And the winner of Anime of the Year is...
JUJUTSU KAISEN
MAPPA
We also actually have an acceptance
message from Sunghoo Park,
the director of JUJUTSU KAISEN.
So, let me read it out.
"Sunghoo Park, director of the
anime JUJUTSU KAISEN here.
We're overjoyed to be able
to win such an award today.
Our staff is currently coming
together and continuing to work hard
as we make our way toward the final episode.
We hope you'll all continue
watching until the very end.
We'd also like to take this moment
to express our deep gratitude
to all of the fans around the
world supporting JUJUTSU KAISEN.
Thank you very much.
Sunghoo Park"
Oh wow! Congratulations to JUJUTSU KAISEN!
And what a treat that we
got a personal acceptance.
So Tim, what did ya think?
That was a wild ride, Hime.
I can't believe 2020's Anime
of the Year is JUJUTSU KAISEN!
So, what do you all think about the winners?
I know that chat's been going off.
Before we go, we have to give a
big thanks to our official judges
and thanks to all of you fans for helping to
name our winners tonight and for tuning in!
Thank you to our co-streamers for
extending the party to their channels.
Let us know on social media how you
felt about this year's results,
and please send a note of congratulations
to our wonderful winners.
And finally, thank you, anime!
You provided so many
remarkable shows this year,
and without you, there would
be no anime, obviously.
And no Anime Awards, full stop!
Be sure to go to crunchyroll.com
to watch some anime
and enjoy what 2021 brings.
I'm Tim Lyu.
And I am Crunchyroll Hime.
Thanks for watching everyone!
Bye now!
All right, Tim. Ready to
go back to your world?
Thanks Hime, but—ah, no thanks.
I think I wanna stay right here.